boum boum boum boum en 1999 Johnny Depp
et sa paradis donne naissance à
Lily-Rose Depp fruit de leur amour j'ai
envie de l'embrasser ça fait cinq jours
que je l'ai pas vu
et aujourd'hui
âgé de 24 ans la jeune femme devenue
actrice vient d'annoncer être en couple
avec Daniel Balbuena une rappeuse
américaine qui cumule plusieurs millions
de vues et avec qui elle avait été déjà
aperçu complice
[Musique]
après avoir été avec l'acteur Timothée
chalamé Lily-Rose Depp vient donc de
faire récemment son coming out en
officialisant sa relation qui daterait
de six mois et en postant des photos et
des messages d'amour joyeux anniversaire
amour de ma vie je t'aime Dany alors à
telle raison d'exposer publiquement son
couple
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
en fait voilà donc ça fait 4 mois
qu'elle est qu'elle est avec cette jeune
femme qui est en fait considérée comme
la figure montante la figure cuir
montante dans le rap et donc elle est
Nicolas Pernic
et donc elle a annoncé qu'elle était
ensemble il y a 4 mois là on met elle
lui a souhaité son anniversaire et puis
il y a quelques jours elle nous a offert
ce sublime baiser avec cette rappeuse
leur Lily-Rose Depp elle a toujours dit
qu'elle ne voulait pas voilà qu'on lui
met une étiquette à savoir si elle est
hétéro allégée elle se voilà elle
pourrait si vous aimez quelque chose à
jour à tel dit alors vous l'aimez et si
vous aimez autre chose l'autre jour pas
de souci voilà et comment gel en fait
merci merci pour vos commentaires